my first gig was I was on Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and this is when
nobody listened to him nobody Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and the character I
was a character who didn't make the show
but they still showed the character so
it was too it's funny it was the
Amsterdam kids and it was two kids who
were misinformed about Amsterdam's
liberal social policies maybe I'll put
this on air it's and it was just like
hey Conan man I had this long hair down
in my shoulder something like he's like
yeah so it's the Amsterdam kids folks
and I go yeah Conan you know man in
Amsterdam you could just squawk down in
the middle of the street and take a dump
and no one will care man it's
performance art cone he's like no no no
no that that's not true no it's true and
we I went on and on and it turned into
like six episodes and it was so
heartbroken when they stopped but you
know what kind of always bothered me
I was a guest on Conan O'Brien and I and
I like Conan
but